- Do you like producing or acting better?
- I like both, honestly.
But I definitely wanna do
more producing as well.
Like it just feels...
You know, in life like, as you...
- A little bit of ownership?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Well, and even collaborating though.
So you were telling me, we
ran into each other years ago,
and I literally left going,
oh my God, I just met Jessie Spano!
I was freaking out, and it was crazy.
- Meantime, I'm freaking
out probably over here.
You're freaking out over there.
'Cause like I'm obsessed
with your music, so.
- Well, we had a freak
out moment together then.
But then it cut to, now we're here,
and you're doing "Saved
By The Bell" the reunion.
So I think the reboot is so cool.
I had Mario on and we
talked about it a bit.
'Cause I already got really mad at him.
- Why, tell me.
- 'Cause he was the first
cast member to come on.
And I was like, hey, I
knew the whole theme song.
Like, I'm a really great jingle singer.
I could have done the theme song.
- You could have done it amazing.
- Oh my God, I would have...
You have no idea, I
freaking saw every episode
at 10:00 AM every morning
in Texas, it's fine.
So like, is that kind of cool
getting back, like so many years later?
- Honestly, it's the best.
Like the core four of us have
never stopped being in touch.
We are friends, I know their children.
I'm friends with their spouses.
You know, so to then drop back in,
I remember sitting across from Mario,
like the first day of shooting at The Max.
- At The Max!
- Yeah.
- I love it.
- And I'm sitting there
looking at this face
that I have known through the years.
We were truly children when we started.
- I know!
- If someone had told me
then that I would see him
this many years later
back as that character,
I wouldn't have believed it.
- I know, but it was such
a huge pop culture moment.
Like few people are part
of something that massive,
that makes such an impact.
- So my question that I asked him,
so AC Slater is now the athletic director.
- Yes.
- So who is Jessie Spano?
- So Jessie, in perfect Jessie Spano form,
is the guidance counselor, okay?
- Oh my god, I love it.
- 'Cause like even back in the day,
with the OG friends, she
was always the advice giver.
She was always wanting to help people.
And she was an advocate for
so many different causes
and her son, Jamie is a student here.
So she's a bit of a helicopter parent,
and thus comedy ensues.